and now the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
today has spoken to Vladimir zielinski
saying that Ukraine can count on the UK
to provide support for the long term
this comes after president zielinski
Board of a step up in Russian drone
attacks well Russia's defense Ministry
has admitted that 63 soldiers were
killed in a missile stripe that
destroyed a temporary barracks in the
east of Ukraine Ukraine claims up to 400
soldiers were killed
uh let's get the latest on the situation
now joining me is retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell uh Sean good to see
you let's talk about
um the prime minister's commitment to
Ukraine you know again reiterating it to
Vladimir zelensky long-term support for
Ukraine what's your reaction to that
it's important that this is said you
know openly isn't it just to bolster
morale not just weapons and financial
aid yeah I think you're right there's
two sides to it and the UK has been a
long-term supporter of this war in
Ukraine it was a great opportunity for
the two leader to discuss the progress
of the war but also discuss these
Relentless strikes on the critical
National infrastructure of Ukraine and
also how to combat that almost certainly
president zelenski took the opportunity
to thank sunac as well because we've
just completed delivery of about a
thousand surface-to-air missile systems
to Ukraine and undoubtedly they've been
part of the reason that Ukrainian
military is becoming more and more
effective at shooting down some of the
Russian missiles
um president zielinski said this morning
Russia is going to step up their drone
attacks on Ukraine what do you make of
those comments yeah they're Relentless
waves of attack they've been going on
all over Christmas and New Year as well
a lot of them being conducted using the
Shaheed 136 drone from Iran let me
targeting the critical National energy
infrastructure of Ukraine across the
whole country and it's worth
re-emphasizing games these are not
military targets so why is Russia keep
doing it I think there's three main
reasons one of which is to try and erode
the will of the population it may be
cold in the UK it's fearsomely cold out
in uh in Ukraine at the moment and
therefore if you make life as miserable
as possible for the population
potentially undermines support for
zielinski in reality it seems to have
quite the opposite effect second reason
is that Russia's
retribution because things are not going
well for the Russians on the battlefield
they've given up 50 of the territory
that they once had taken and also the
ukrainians have effectively targeted the
Engels Air Force Base you know
comfortably some way behind the front
line and thirdly it's momentum Russia
needs momentum on the battlefield it
needs to buy time it needs to buy time
to rearm retrain re-equip and get ready
for a spring offensive and if you can
distract the Ukrainian military by
having to track and then shoot down all
these missiles potentially that's
another reason why they're doing it and
can I just go back to something we
mentioned at the start of this and that
was the attack on the temporary Russian
Barracks inside Ukraine what more are we
hearing about that attack
well yes it was a Ukrainian strike on a
a Russian military concentration point
it was happened at makiefke here which
you'll see is literally only about 13
kilometers away from the front line so
it's very very close the attack was done
using the Ukrainian high mass system
which has been provided by the American
it's been used since about June of the
year it's got about 100 kilometers at
range the ukrainians as you say claim
that they have killed 400 Russians and
300 casualties in response the Russians
have said that they uh they acknowledge
the attack they say two of the six
missiles that were fired they managed to
shoot down but four got through and they
admit that 63 Russians lost their lives
now in this information War what
actually happened is actually very
difficult for us to say what is
interesting is that Russians rarely turn
around and confirm any reports like this
so the very fact they've admitted it is
very telling and also independent
sources we're seeing some of the
wreckage here independent sources say
that about over 600 military personnel
were to be present in this facility so
it's quite feasible that there were
large number of casualties I think the
two main points come from this for me
one of which is the use of precisional
weapons by Ukraine provided by the West
Russian at the moment is provide is
using 20 000 artillery rounds a day
carpet bombing they're unguided with
limited effects apart from just
devastating everywhere around them
whereas the use of position weapons are
Salva four weapons can actually have a
devastating effect on the battlefield
and the second point I would make is
that this is a really good example of
what happens when you use conscript Army
that ill-experienced ill-equipped
ill-trained and lacking the right
equipment because first of all they
should not have all been collecting at a
point so close to the front line and
secondly if reports are to be believed
many of the conscripts will use their
own mobile phones they are very easily
tracked and once you get a collection of
those together that will be all the
intelligence that will be needed to make
that a key Focus for an attack so it's a
really clear lesson which the Russians
have paid a huge price for not learning
yeah clearly as you can see from these
scenes I'm Sean thank you Sean Bell